if you're ready for something new when
Metal Gear Solid 5 you'll be excited for
the new multiplayer expansion coming in
March
it's called cloaked in silence and it
adds a bunch of new stuff to Metal Gear
Online Clifden silence brings three new
maps coral complex is modeled after
mother base rust palace is a ruined
building in Afghanistan and Azure
Mountain is an outdoor plane in Africa
and if you didn't already guess by the
name the expansion also adds quiet as a
playable character all that good stuff
will cost you a measly $4 the expansion
also includes a new feature called
appeal action for 2 bucks a piece you
can grab packs of poses you can initiate
during battle if you want your avatar to
dance after every kill now you can do
that finally a new mission type will
launch alongside the expansion sabotage
tasks players with either destroying or
fall turning the enemy's missile this
part of the update will be completely
free the phantom pain recently ships 6
million copies so there should be plenty
of operators ready to hop into this new
content in March if Konami announced is
more about Metal Gear before then you'll
hear about it from GameSpot we don't
keep you waiting
[Music]